[Música]
y
a cadena perpetua sin derecho a libertad
condicional fue condenados a la app de
slam el único sobreviviente de un grupo
de integrantes del autodenominado estado
islámico que realizaron una serie de
atentados terroristas con bombas y
tiroteos el 13 de noviembre de 2015 en
parís la capital francesa 130 personas
perdieron la vida en esos hechos siendo
considerados los más mortíferos ataques
en tiempos de paz es decir desde el fin
de la segunda guerra mundial en francia
recordemos los hechos en el siguiente
informe que preparó la redacción de
france 24
el viernes 13 de noviembre de 2015 una
noche de horror acaba de comenzar el
primer atentado tuvo lugar a las afueras
del estadio nacional de francia cuando
dos terroristas suicidas se inmolaron
con diez minutos de diferencia un tercer
ataque suicida tuvo lugar menos de media
hora después el presidente françois
hollande que se encontraba en el estadio
en el que se disputaba un partido
amistoso contra alemania fue puesto a
salvo al mismo tiempo se producían más
ataques en el centro de la capital
francesa hombres armados dispararon a
los comensales de un café y un
restaurante de la calle aliviar en el
distrito 10
[Música]
minutos después abrieron fuego en la
calle puntano y en la calle en el
distrito 11
había sangre por todas partes la gente
caía como moscas era una verdadera
escena de guerra me sentía como en las
trincheras
pero el peor ataque de la noche comenzó
cuando tres terroristas se
interrumpieron en la sala de conciertos
bataclán y abrieron fuego con armas
automáticas tenían como blanco 1500
personas que asistían a un concierto de
rock
[Aplausos]
un periodista de lemont que vivía al
lado filmó a algunos de los asistentes
al concierto escapando por una puerta
trasera y a otros colgando de las
ventanas intentando desesperadamente
salir algunos de los que estaban
atrapados dentro se escondieron donde
pudieron
dos policías llegaron y mataron a uno de
los terroristas en la planta baja otros
dos estaban arriba habían tomado rehenes
las fuerzas especiales de la policía
francesa ingresaron aseguraron la planta
baja y los rehenes salieron
y
estábamos todos tirados en el piso y vi
que disparaban por todas partes sentí un
instinto de supervivencia estábamos
todos en el suelo nadie se movía nos
tumbamos lo más bajo posible para que no
nos vieran o para conjugar los riesgos
por con guille a toda la gente se acostó
encima de los demás disparaban
kalashnikovs como si estuvieran
torturando a la gente se disparaba
contra la gente era una carnicería una
carnicería había muertos por todas
partes
el presidente francés se dirigió a la
nación justo antes de la medianoche
con ciudadanos mientras hablo se están
produciendo atentados terroristas de una
magnitud sin precedentes en parís varias
decenas de personas han muerto y muchas
han resultado heridas es un horror
y digamos cumbres e
el sitio tras intentar negociar con
ellos las fuerzas francesas asaltaron a
los dos terroristas que tenían como
rehenes a los asistentes al concierto la
operación terminó veintiún minutos
después de la medianoche después de tres
horas de derramamiento de sangre fueron
los atentados más mortíferos en francia
desde la segunda guerra mundial
este tribunal especial también condenó a
otros 19 hombres implicados en estos
mismos hechos tras un juicio que tomó
prácticamente 10 meses teniendo en vilo
a la sociedad francesa y también a
europa que significa entonces para
francia esta condena que elecciones en
materia de seguridad y terrorismo dejan
estos hechos hoy después de darse a
conocer este veredicto se puede hacer un
poco de memoria y ver qué fue lo que
falló ese 13 de noviembre de 2015
condena a cadena perpetua sin derecho a
libertad condicional es tal vez una pena
justa es suficiente una apelación es
completamente posible pero es viable
analizamos este tema en unos minutos
aquí en el debate de france 24 para
conversar sobre estos hechos saludamos a
chema hill él es director de estudios de
seguridad de universal el licenciado en
seguridad por la universidad de murcia y
también diplomado en estudios
internacionales sobre terrorismo por la
cátedra unesco se conecta desde la
ciudad de cartagena en españa pero desde
málaga también se une a esta
conversación julián mateos él es
analista de políticas de seguridad y
defensa les recuerdo que ustedes también
a ser parte de esta conversación a
través de nuestras redes sociales antes
de dar paso al debate y de comenzar a
analizar este tema con nuestros
invitados me conecto con erika olavarría
nuestra corresponsal permanente en la
ciudad de parís en francia quien estuvo
allí en la corte allí en la ciudad de
parís siguiendo minuto a minuto el
desarrollo de la lectura de este
veredicto y vamos a conocer algunas de
las impresiones que dejó estos hechos el
día de hoy erika gracias por estar con
nosotros en el programa gracias por
acompañarnos y cuáles son las
impresiones que deja este veredicto los
comentarios que se vivían en el lugar y
también las primeras impresiones que hay
por parte de la sociedad francesa a raíz
de este veredicto dado a conocer hoy
hola santiago buenas noches bueno hay
que decir que ha sido un día con mucho
estrés aquí con mucho nerviosismo y
mucha angustia también porque ustedes lo
han vivido a través de los informativos
de frank 64 ese veredicto tardó en
llegar se había fijado a las cinco y
media de la tarde y finalmente llegó a
las ocho y media de la tarde tres unas
de tensa espera como podríamos decir
además en una sala en la que hacía calor
la gente tenía hambre estaba cansada
pero finalmente llegó el presidente dijo
son 120 hojas las de este veredicto pero
yo voy a hacerles un resumen hubo
sonrisas de la prensa y bueno lo que
ustedes ya han escuchado no es a cadena
perpetua irreductible para salvarte slam
que comienza a ser vista como un símbolo
en realidad porque lo que nos decía hoy
una abogada y en realidad la cadena
perpetua existe pero nunca se aplica
como que no no está concebida para ser
aplicada lo máximo siempre se piensa que
son 30 años de cárcel de hecho incluso
siendo irreductible él podría no cierto
a partir de 30 años pedir una reducción
de su pena entonces se le ha dado a él
ya su amigo mohamed abril y como ustedes
bien decían pero los otros tres acusados
presentes en este juicio que estaban
condenados a cadena perpetua se le ha
reducido a 30 años y justamente para
algunas de las víctimas sobre todo que
en realidad querían mucho este juicio
eso es visto como una excepción yo
conversaba recién con el padre una de
las víctimas él me ponía no porque por
sms un emoticón de una carita enojada y
como en cólera roja no porque para él no
es suficiente porque además esos que
eran conocidos como las pequeñas manos
aquellos que ayudaron a salas de slam a
viajar desde parís hasta bélgica el día
del 13 de noviembre esas personas vieron
incluso reducidas sus penas son quiénes
comparecían libres son tres personas y
largo estaban libres y ya han cumplido
parte de la pena en lo que dura este
proceso van a salir muy pronto van a
terminar muy pronto van a tener van a
dejar de tener responsabilidad digamos
penal en este caso cuando pues el todo
tipo de
respuesta en torno a este veredicto
erika ha sido un proceso muy largo han
sido muchos años en un cubrimiento muy
extenso al que ha hecho también france24
sobre este tema hubo también desgaste de
la población de los medios de
comunicación de la prensa de los
familiares de las víctimas de los que
sobrevivieron a esto francia cierra
entonces este capítulo como lo ve usted
si yo lo veo así ahora hay que ver lo
que van a decir los abogados de los
acusados concretamente de sala de slam
pero yo siempre pensaba que este juicio
era necesario sobre todo para las
víctimas yo mencionaba que a mí me
parecía muy difícil siempre encontrar
testimonios de las víctimas porque
imagino creo que no ni siquiera puedo
imaginar el dolor que sienten personas
que han perdido a alguien en una
situación tan terrible como esta y
quienes han logrado sobrevivir que a
veces sufren más que aquellos que han
perdido a un familiar por lo tanto ellos
yo pensaba les cuesta mucho contar su
historia pero finalmente este juicio al
escuchar sus testimonios me da la
sensación que para ellos ha sido
necesario ha sido catárquico han se han
hecho amigos entre ellos han puesto un
dolor tan grande en común y eso quizás
ha hecho que para ellos el dolor sea
menos realizado de hecho usted decía son
130 víctimas pero hay que decir que hay
dos víctimas que se suicidaron no
soportaron haber sobrevivido y esas
personas muchos de los que vinieron a
este juicio quizás también habían pasado
por una situación como ella pero estaba
haciendo en cierta forma terapéutico
este juicio sobre todo yo creo para
ellos hay gente de la sociedad francesa
que se cuesta porque se hace este
proceso porque se abren viejas heridas
porque mejor no ponerle tierra y pasar
página pero creo que era necesario
yo le decía una cosa con respecto a lo
que pensaban los familiares sin embargo
los abogados justamente por lo que te
mencionaba de que las penas la cadena
perpetua es una pena muy dura yo pienso
que en general a nivel profesional están
satisfechos con esta con este veredicto
los abogados erika pues muchas gracias
por estas impresiones este reporte desde
la ciudad de parís excelente cubrimiento
a lo largo de la jornada de hoy en torno
a esta noticia que tiene en vilo no
solamente a parís y a francia sino
también a europa ya buena parte del
mundo muchas gracias erika por este
reporte vamos entonces ahora al análisis
sobre estos hechos que han tenido lugar
hoy en parís saludó entonces a chema gil
ya julián mateos ellos están en españa
los dos gracias por acompañarnos hoy en
el programa punto de partida es decir la
primera pregunta para conocer
impresiones para dar inicio al análisis
y comienzo entonces con con chema
preguntándole el significado de esta
condena lo que significa para francia
para la sociedad de este país para la
justicia y para el terrorismo
internacional
bueno pues para el terrorismo
internacional desgraciadamente no supere
nada supone prácticamente
pues un hito más dentro de lo que es la
dinámica criminal de los grupos
terroristas y parte de esta naturaleza
ahora bien hay que poder que yo creo que
erika describía muy bien es un momento
catártico un juicio 184 días de
descripción verdaderamente intenso esto
de unos sucesos que conmocionaron no
solamente a francia sino al mundo entero
y hay que recordar una cuestión no aquí
no se cierra ningún capítulo o no se
cierra un libro se puede cerrar un
capítulo el capítulo concreto de la
noche del 13 de noviembre pero adquiere
el 3 de noviembre fue continuado con
unas operaciones policiales e intentos
de atentados el propio 18 de noviembre
se evitaron ataques continuó la búsqueda
de sala gades land el 15 de marzo hay
que recordar como about us
plantaron batalla y estaban preparados
para atentar de nuevo en parís en el
equipo financiero como se continúa la
búsqueda en el trabajo de la policía
francesa verdaderamente extraordinario y
un trabajo de coordinación con la
inteligencia marrón incluso que dio
lugar a la localización definitivamente
en bélgica el gran refugio de esos
terroristas y como después de la
detención de salvajadas grand pues se
producen los atentados el 23 de marzo -
a generar un proceso de bruselas y en la
ciudad quiere decir que es en los
sucesos de parís por los supuestos de
parís con los sucesos de bruselas y es
la continuación de aquella dinámica
criminal clave parece ahora querer
olvidarse pero que hemos de estar muy
atentos porque hay un momento
metamórfico dentro del terrorismo
yihadista especialmente lo estamos
viendo como lo que está pasando en
áfrica y que yo creo que
desgraciadamente nos va a ofrecer nuevos
cumplimientos en europa temas ya vamos a
analizar ese tema lo tengo nuestros
temas de análisis para el programa le
doy la bienvenida a julián mateos en la
ciudad de málaga en el sur de españa su
punto de partida impresiones de lo que
significa julián esta condena el
significado para francia ya vemos que
para chema no es el fin del libro es el
fin de un capítulo y hay múltiples
puntos de análisis a partir de ese 13 de
noviembre del 2015 al día de hoy
pues en primer lugar y efectivamente y
ni siquiera ni siquiera un cierre de
capítulo porque como se ha visto en la
introducción todavía no es una condena
firme es decir que cada recurso por lo
tanto y muy a mi pesar teniendo en
cuenta que la pena es la máxima para el
principal acusado lo más probable es que
nos encontremos ante un recurso que
significa esto para francia pues
evidentemente para francia pero también
para el mundo como decía el tema
evidentemente para los terroristas esto
tiene poco poco calado pero sí es verdad
que lo que se pretende es hacer ver que
el estado de derecho funciona es decir
nos habéis atacado habéis apartado a la
sociedad pero nosotros ponemos aquí un
juicio un juicio justo y además con
todas las garantías posibles y en ese
sentido lo que ha hecho la fiscalía es
para una pena para un ataque de una
índole pues como hemos visto criminal de
éste de esta categoría pedir la máxima
pena posible he estado echando un ojo
históricamente creo que es sólo con
anterioridad en cuatro ocasiones se
había dictado esta sentencia es decir de
cadena perpetua sin posibilidad de ser
revocada en cuatro las cuatro veces
anteriores habían sido para asesinos en
serie por lo tanto nos da una de cómo se
ha tomado la justicia este proceso y
luego además también es una y además es
un proceso que seguro que vamos a
analizar es tremendamente complejo
dilatado inter de las víctimas hasta
todo lo que ha rodeado el proceso no hay
que olvidar que han pasado por el
tribunal como como intervinientes en la
declaración desde atrás a hollande hasta
el propio vocalista del grupo que
actuaba en la sala bataclán es decir que
ha tenido un compendio de circunstancias
que lo han hecho verdaderamente
extraordinario sin olvidar al final de
lo que se trata que es dar una de lo que
se llama una verdad jurídica y una
condena a unos hechos tan deleznables
julián continuó con usted para hacer la
ronda a la inversa ya le doy la palabra
chema usted dice un hecho extraordinario
esto sin duda alguna sienta precedentes
para francia y también para la unión
europea y otros países del viejo
continente y es enseñanzas en temas de
seguridad y de la forma como se puede
enfrentar el terrorismo y esa amenaza
latente que efectivamente continúa
europa puede seguir enfrentando hechos
similares en el futuro próximo eso no
hay duda alguna qué enseñanzas deja esto
que precedentes deja esto para francia y
para el resto del continente en materia
de seguridad
pues en principio con respecto a la
parte a la parte de lo que es el proceso
legal de la parte jurídica
la primera es que hemos encontrado una
novedad en ese sentido parte de la una
parte muy importante de la de la defensa
de abberline era decir que él pues por
humanidad no había detonado el chaleco
cuando la en este caso la fiscal y ha
demostrado el que la pericial que el
chaleco tuvo un fallo técnico y lo que
ha hecho que lo que digo que es esta
parte novedad que se ha establecido en
esa lectura resumida que ha habido del
fallo es tener en cuenta es decir
calificar el hecho en sí los múltiples
hechos que hemos visto pues las
detonaciones con los chalecos bomba
suicida en el stade france el ataque
previo a las distintas cafeterías y
luego la sala bataclán se ha juzgado
como un único hecho de ahí que esa
condena sea por homicidio con
perpetuación terrorista y haya permitido
esa pues esa condena y al final de lo
que se trata a ir dando de ir dando
pasos en esa dirección ya tenemos aquí
una novedad en este caso jurídica pues
vamos avanzando en ese sentido con
respecto a españa pues con la ley que
permite lugar completar el proceso de
adoctrinamiento sin necesidad de llegar
a tener al delincuente en este caso al
terrorista cometiendo la acción y luego
hay una cosa más importante que estoy
seguro que es la que va a incidir
también el tema y es que fue darnos
cuenta de una cosa y los autores habían
nacido y se habían criado o bien en
francia o bien en bélgica es decir en el
corazón de europa no venían no habían
sido nacidos no venían formados de otros
territorios exteriores se habían formado
aquí y creo que eso aunque era un
problema que estaba encima de la mesa sí
fue algo que el acto o que porque la
opinión pública en este sentido que no
que no tenía esa constancia sí sí que
despertó a ese problema si fue fue
impactante ver como un ciudadano francés
atentaba contra su propio país chema
impresiones sobre este tema es su
opinión
y yo creo que ha puesto dedo sobre la
llaga
es que es así hemos de tomar conciencia
de que los terroristas que están
atentando que han intentado en europa en
los últimos años son muy jóvenes nacidos
criados aquí que han nacido en países
con derechos con libertades y sin
embargo para ellos no parece que se
sintieran contenidos por los valores de
la república francesa de ese gran país
igual que ha ocurrido por ejemplo
ocurrieron los atentados de barcelona
con chavales que estaban criados de
algunos nacidos aquí en españa y esto ha
de hacernos reflexionar sobre algunas
causas profundas
cuando se produce cuando cuando un grupo
terrorista es capaz de manipular el
corazón y la mente de jóvenes a los
cuales les llega a ofrecer una
identificación
pues puede hacer muy posible la
captación cuando hay gente que no se
siente vinculada efectivamente a su
entorno y aquí no estamos hablando sólo
de si es pobre pobreza sin inclinación
desde luego en esos entornos el caldo de
cultivo está servido no pero aquí vamos
más allá y vamos a personas que siendo
franceses siendo parisinos incluso
algunos de ellos por parís para ellos no
era la de las plantes ni es la ciudad de
los campos y vicios ni es la ciudad
maravillosa que es parís sino que es la
banda es la marginación es un entorno
donde no se sienten reconocidos se
sienten concernidos por los valores de
francia pero tampoco se sienten
concebidos por valores de país de origen
que ni siquiera conocen ni siquiera
referencialmente por lo tanto nos
encontramos con un fenómeno terrorista
que es muy potente en el uso de las
redes sociales que se ofrece como un
identificador del sujeto el sujeto se
siente reconocido se siente afectado la
siente que ese mensaje dirigido al
corazón ya la mente le puede llevar a
hacer algo más importante que el mismo
tema todo eso es una cuestión compleja
sobre la que tendrá que trabajar y no
obstante hemos de poner de manifiesto
que hay en una memoria del pec en europa
porque está mi nación ha pasado ha
habido atentados terroristas y cádiz
europa y ha habido muertos clark apenas
ha salido a los medios de comunicación
chema es decir y profundizando en este
tema que estos grupos terroristas han
encontrado en un fallo digamos en la
sociedad francesa en este caso que es el
que estamos analizando en ese proceso de
integración a pesar de que ellos son ya
una primera generación de migrantes que
llegaron a este país que han crecido con
los valores democráticos y en una
sociedad abierta
encontraron que tal vez está ese fallo
en la integración que tal vez no no veo
uno muy firme en otros países como por
ejemplo suecia que tiene un proceso de
integración muy riguroso para las
personas que llegan a vivir en su
territorio
aunque suecia tienen también algunos
problemas declaró que el sitio pequeño
fijaos es que
de acuerdo conmigo pero hemos reducido
el término integración a una conducta
amazonía en relación con unos pares es
decir con gente de un entorno la
integración sí sólo eso creemos que va a
servir para que alguien se sienta
identificado ya estado como hablamos de
afectación hablamos de tripas de corazón
de sentimiento de pertenencia que
creemos que la integración sólo es
posible no integración tiene que incluir
tiene que llegar integrada el ternero
inclusión tengo que sentirme
perteneciente a es decir los valores de
ciudadanía tienen que ser compartidos
conmigo porque todos los ciudadanos
independientemente de nuestras
ideologías religiones aspectos y venas
debemos sentirnos concernidos por todo
aquello que nos pueda amenazar como
ciudadanos y en este caso se ofrecen
entornos de captación a través de redes
sociales a través de en fin desde
múltiples fórmulas de captación que son
muy bien utilizados por los grupos
terroristas hay elementos para
facilitadores en toda europa y hemos de
saber que esta amenaza que parece que en
estos momentos ha entrado en un momento
de bailén
sin embargo en áfrica está cometiendo
directamente atentados promoviendo
incluso golpes de estado en toda la
franja sahelo sahariana desde el cuerno
de áfrica hasta la costa atlántica y no
estamos hablando de europa de todos esos
muertos por lo tanto creemos que ese
terrorismo que atentó en parís es
diferente al que se ha intentando en
áfrica pues es el mismo es la misma
ideología criminal que se dirige de una
y de otra manera a conquistar espacios
de poder y esa amenaza que están
creciendo en áfrica es una amenaza que
está dirigida y que va a tender a tener
un poco directo hacia francia alañá
italia y demás pero la palabra julián su
opinión sobre este tema
coincido plenamente y en este caso que
nos encontramos y redundando en este
sentido que juegan con esta segunda
generación de jóvenes ya nacidos en
europa en francia principalmente
esa falta de sentido de pertenencia y no
se escucharon antes en el especial que
ha habido en directo a fernando cacho
que enumeraba una serie de
circunstancias la pobreza de la
educación es fundamental pero nos
encontramos con jóvenes y el ejemplo
también lo tenemos encima de la mesa de
los atentados de la ramba si de cambrils
jóvenes estaban integrados jóvenes que
tenían un trabajo es decir que habían
estado acompañados por la propia
administración una formación un trabajo
pleno cuál es el problema hay un momento
crítico principalmente en la
adolescencia en el que este estos
individuos no se sienten franceses no se
sienten españoles pero tampoco se
sienten marroquíes tampoco se sienten
tunecinos es decir ese sentido de no
saber a qué pertenecen es lo que ha
sabido y saben como nadie el estado
islámico para darle un sentido de
pertenencia es decir tú eres un miembro
del califato tus misiones están nosotros
somos tus hermanos y eso fuera de
control son unas mentes que están
atravesando ese proceso personal crítico
que no se encuentran integrados en el
sentido de y aquí incluso a los países
de orígenes de sus padres porque no son
sus países porque ya han nacido en
europa es lo que ha sabido usar de forma
primo seminarios de sentido el estado
islámico y hacer bastante daño en esos
jóvenes encuentran un porqué para
existir y un
supuesto espacio para poder aportar algo
a un grupo determinado quiero pasar
ahora al tema de la justicia esto fue un
proceso muy largo fue un juicio largo
desgastante lo hablábamos con erika
tanto para la sociedad para las víctimas
para los familiares para los medios de
comunicación julián la justicia francesa
está entonces una respuesta a ese
reclamo ciudadano ante los hechos
ocurridos
y un pedido que hacía buena parte de la
población del país
completamente y además han puesto a los
medios en el tribunal donde se ha
juzgado es una sala creada el proceso
para éste el procedimiento es un proceso
largo larguísimo prácticamente un año
diez meses de declaraciones
y además que pasan no solamente hemos
llegado al punto del veredicto que me
bajo mi punto de vista al final la
verdad jurídica y esas condenas son
acordes a la magnitud del atentado a la
magnitud de lo que se estaba juzgando es
decir un atentado que se lleva por
delante 130 personas 400 heridos
infinidad en este caso de víctimas
indirectas pues no puede terminar de
otra forma que con la mayor condena que
permite el ordenamiento jurídico francés
y luego además también es un proceso
liberador en el sentido de que los
familiares de las víctimas por crudo que
sea y me costó además por procesos
previos agradecen por lo menos el saber
cómo han sido esos momentos previos cómo
se desarrolló la situación y se han
vivido testimonios muy crudos y luego
además y esto también es será ordinario
y no entró a valorar
a la pureza de la declaración pero no es
habitual que alguien es decir que uno de
los miembros del comando que actúe se
sea juzgado porque no suelen sobrevivir
en el propio hecho de que como te digo
sin incidir en que sea mayor o menor el
grado de arrepentimiento pero lo haya
escuchado de sus labios de redland ese
perdón a las víctimas eso también ayuda
dentro del conjunto de lo que es el
marco jurídico no hacen dar página
porque es imposible pero así ha sido
esa ayuda a los familiares de las
víctimas ya sean directas son directas
que han estado presentes en el proceso
estoy corriendo un poco con las
preguntas porque ya me queda poco tiempo
ya entra en la parte final del programa
chema estamos hablando en cuanto al
proceso como tal a ese juicio que se
extendió por un poco más de 10 meses
hablemos ahora de la condena
satisfactoria es lo que los familiares
de las víctimas pedían hay ciertos
sectores que se han mostrado
decepcionados nos contaba a erika
olavarría nuestra corresponsal en parís
al darse a conocer este este veredicto
esta condena como lo ve usted cuál es su
análisis
y coincido con julián ese es un proceso
absolutamente impecable muy duro pero
donde la carga probatoria ha sido
llevada al extremo
las sentencias las condenas más duras
están perfectamente especificadas ahora
bien hay que reconocer el dolor de las
víctimas las víctimas son las que nunca
desaparecen después de un atentado
terrorista son eterna y esas víctimas
cuando ven que se reduce la condena de
alguien expulsado por participar por el
apoyo logístico a los atentados etcétera
desde luego tienen que sentir alguna
frustración sin embargo como decía
julián presentar ese juicio del que se
dice que se aplica el estado de derecho
es algo que te ayuda a sobrellevar una
situación que realmente es el dolor es
el dolor
eterno
no obstante hemos de poner de manifiesto
que los ordenamientos jurídicos europeos
y españoles adoptó se adaptó en 2015
en el ordenamiento jurídico español en
esa adaptación adelanta la posibilidad
de la actuación policial para frustrar
los ataques es decir en el momento en el
que se detectan los procesos de auto
entrenamiento y captación ya la policía
tiene la carga suficiente al menos para
hacer la detención y podrán elegir un
proceso penal y yo creo que eso debe ser
aplicado por tan en general por el
conjunto de los países sobre todo por la
unión europea y más en los momentos que
vamos a vivir a partir de este año
importante es a ese punto chema le
pregunto ahora por la apelación que es
completamente posible en este marco
jurídico la defensa lo puede hacer es
viable lo ve usted como un escenario
posible que nos podemos enfrentar en
unos cuantos meses en españa hay un
dicho popular gris de pleitos tengas y
los ganes
es posible claro es posible ahora yo
creo que la condena de sala gades las
principales condenas están perfectamente
fundamentadas es posibles ya ya y así
binay actuarán los abogados en defensa
de sus el de sus patrocinadores pero
creo que va a ser muy difícil levantar
las determinadas sentencias creo que es
muy difícil levantar determinadas
sentencias porque yo creo que el fallo
todo historia policial toda la
investigación ha quedado bastante
acreditada incluso el detalle que decía
julián nos aleja de slam en un alarde de
cobardía de cobardía de no
reconocimiento dice que no detonó el por
humanidad el chaleco bomba cuando se
sabe que no fue así porque estalló por
lo tanto yo creo que es posible a fin
que se presenten las alegaciones pero en
mi opinión en la sentencia del fallo va
a estar muy bien fundamentado de lo que
sabemos yo creo que sí y esperemos que
pronto pues esto pueda pasar puede hacer
pasar la página definitiva a las
víctimas sobre salud que son las que
tienen que servir como guía moral no
como referencia moral respecto de estas
cuestiones julián muy puntual antes de
pasar a las conclusiones para cerrar el
programa algo que añadir en torno a la
condena satisfactoria es lo que la gente
esperaba los familiares y la sociedad
esperaba
evidentemente los familiares siempre
desean no no no es un sentido de
venganza sino que oye ya que tenemos que
pasar por esto que el criminal cumpla la
máxima pena posible por lo tanto
evidentemente es muy comprensible que
para ello sea una descripción pero en
conjunto las penas son acordes a la
verdad jurídica porque luego es verdad
que tenemos un relato pero luego eso hay
que probarlo en un tribunal y luego con
respecto pues a la en este caso a la
revisión coincido con con chema es muy
difícil que se mueva el veredicto pero
yo estoy prácticamente convencido que va
a verse en este caso una petición por
parte de la abogacía porque al final no
tiene nada que perder es decir adela no
ha sido condenada la máxima pena posible
por lo tanto pedir una segunda instancia
pues es una vía más no de dilatar sino
una única puerta que le queda puesto que
no tiene nada que perder ya que ha sido
condenado a la máxima pena posible
pasemos a las conclusiones me quedan ya
pocos minutos para cerrar el programa
comienzo con julián entonces la
conclusión no tenemos bola de cristal
siempre lo digo al cierra este programa
para saber lo que va a suceder pero que
podemos estar viendo en
los próximos meses en torno a este tema
de la radicalización del terrorismo ya
lo decían ustedes sigue siendo una
amenaza latente pero sin duda alguna
tanto la policía como el estado francés
y la sociedad están mejor preparados en
cierta forma a raíz de los hechos que
han vivido allí en francia a qué se
puede estar enfrentando este país
después de este veredicto
pues mira al final por desgracia y eres
una es una atenta a lo largo de la
historia
conforme vas teniendo experiencias vas
cambiando para españa' con respecto al
terrorismo 'yihadista' fue el 11-m
prácticamente no teníamos servicios de
información dedicados a eso porque
estábamos totalmente volcados con la
parte del terrorismo etarra y supuso un
antes y un después y en este sentido
para francia verdad que ha elevado un
cúmulo de atentados estamos hablando de
noviembre de 2015 pero no tenemos que
olvidarnos que es que es el 2015 empezó
el 7 de enero con los atentados en sandy
es decir es una sucesión progresiva para
francia no es algo sorpresivo como
quiero decir y no es que vaya a ser un
punto de inflexión porque ya tenían una
legislación que en ese punto si es si es
previsor a esta novedad con respecto a
la unificación del del concepto de
ataque si coincido igualmente con con
chema creo que esa legislación española
de anteponerse al hecho es decir
intervenir en el proceso de creación
debería ser ejemplo a nivel europeo y en
los próximos meses pista no creo que
vayamos a ver nada que no hayamos visto
es decir
recientemente y también lo comentábamos
con anterioridad se han producido
ataques en europa ataques de índole
yihadista que no han tenido repercusión
prácticamente pública y realmente
estamos viendo operaciones
antiterroristas en todo el continente
creo que es una constante a la que ya
por desgracia nos hemos acostumbrado y
que tienen pocos visos de cambiar y para
el cierre de la palabra a chema a su
conclusión lo que puede pasar lo que
puede venir para francia no solamente en
torno a este tema en específico a este
veredicto lo que pueda suceder sino
también al tema de la seguridad a ese
debate que quedó abierto en torno a la
migración la integración y el terrorismo
pues hay una clave el conocimiento es
algo bueno en sí mismo porque el
conocimiento lo es en sí mismo pero
además para la policía la inteligencia
la gendarmería la policía española para
todo el conjunto de fuerzas que luchan
contra el terrorismo del conocimiento ya
es un requisito operativo y hemos de
saber que la amenaza es constante la
amenaza se mantiene y por más que en
estos momentos tengamos un movimiento en
un momento metamórfico en la
operatividad de los grupos terroristas
hemos de saber que al qaeda está
experimentando un reportorio 500 en
determinadas zonas que se dirigen
amenazas y que en los últimos meses y en
las últimas semanas encontramos vídeos
lanzando amenazas continuas y
advertencias continuas respecto de
francia respecto de españa y demás y
además doblados al español doblados
encuentres y demás hemos de saber que
son en afa time y mantiene constante y
que el conocimiento además de ser bueno
en sí mismo es un requisito operativo ya
definitivamente para todas las pruebas
de seguridad en el ámbito antiterrorista
chema me quedan unos segundos para
preguntarle complementar esto que está
diciendo podemos ver una modificación en
el tipo de acción de estos grupos
terroristas no solamente ir a perpetrar
tiroteos y poner bombas sino una forma
diferente una un avance en términos
tecnológicos en su forma de actuar pues
mira yo creo que
los terroristas han descubierto que yo
no sea tratada derribarlos por el
general y por lo tanto lo que hemos ido
descubriendo es el terrorismo se ha
convertido en en acciones de muy escasa
complejidad organizativa y de alto
impacto
hablábamos antes de antiguamente de
terrorismos low cost de bajo coste no no
ahora mismo es alguien que con un
cuchillo se determina en asesinar a
gente en la calle y esperar a ser
asignado se colocan incluso tal y con
bombas falsos para asegurarse que van a
ser disparados por la policía ese es el
nivel en el sigamos y por lo tanto
debemos saber que esa amenaza y
analizando la teoría de la oportunidad
que estudian criminología sin seguridad
claros llevamos que ese terrorismo es
posible es para ti y por lo tanto lo
tendremos en nuestras calles
desgraciadamente todavía algún diente
punto final muchísimas gracias a chema
gil ya julián mateos por este análisis
por haber explicado esta situación a la
audiencia france24 en américa latina
gracias por habernos acompañado de
ustedes también gracias por la sintonía
sigan con nuestra programación
[Música]